it is a beautiful weekend and we are
going to go on a grand adventure we are
gonna go on a massive fishing camping
trip Tommy and Nate are you guys ready
to go
[Applause]
unfortunately Jacob can't come good boy
for mommy yeah all right let's do this
[Music]
well here we are at the river and we've
got to launch the boat and go downstream
aways to get to where we want to go but
that's the boat ramp all right we're
doing this the hard way all right let's
do this
and now I'm gonna show you a magic trick
I'm gonna make all of my free board
disappear there we go guys we made
a lot of snags over here there we go
hotmail buddies look at this place this
is beautiful that's some nice deep water
right down in there I think this might
be a great spot to fish look at this
guys we barely pull up to this spot and
wouldn't you know it some guy comes
right in up right next to us yeah
someone should really teach that guy
lasted yeah well guys you ready to do
you ready to do some camping all right
let's get the tent out are you having a
good time
well the boys are already wet and the
tent set up so we've got the most
important things done now I'm gonna put
some bait on the rods and we're gonna
try to catch some bluegill we need some
bait well as far as bait is concerned
I'm not seeing a lot of bluegill but I'm
seeing a ton of these baby soccer fish
in the shallows so we're gonna pull out
a cast net and catch a bunch of them try
fishing those live pick them up put them
in there oh these are great minnows oh
look at that
that's great bait right there there we
go there you in there so I've got a
five-foot cast net with fine mesh here
I'll show you how to catch some minnows
so got a Cheeto here but just use a
french fry or a piece of bread throw it
out there and when the fish start
hitting it go for oh hey grab that grab
oh man yeah poultry levan real women can
lurk what you got a piece of bluegill on
there you guys playing with the catfish
so as I was saying before we were so
rudely interrupted take the cheeto throw
it in the water when the minnows start
going for it there we go nice minnows
but these two rods they have a 1 ounce
pyramid lead with a 2 heart circle hook
nothing fancy we're gonna put one of
these minnows on each one of the rods
see what happens there we go let them
hook through the nose like that
well the currents moving a lot stronger
than it looks I ended up having to
upgrade to 3 on sledge to keep things on
the bottom we've got the rods out
fishing the boys playing now we just
need to find some more firewood my
goodness what a beautiful spot well
after that first catfish we really
haven't had much action a couple bites
and that's been about it but it's
getting close to dinnertime so we're
gonna get the fire going and cook up
that catfish and that'll let the Sun get
down a little bit I think once it starts
to get dark and starts to cool off we
might see a lot more action here so
we'll see what happens
[Music]
all right you want to see what these
catfish are eating this that's a
crawfish claw right there that little
shiner clam another minnow clams snail
minnow clam crawfish poop so that right
there is the contents of a channel
catfish this is stomach on this river
quite the smorgasbord it's a big
crawfish I think I might use these for
bait you know what those are those are
catfish eggs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we got a medal I cook it's a fish
something happen oh well there we go cut
a decent-sized deal do you know those
things swim all the way out to the
middle of the Atlantic between North
America and Africa to breathe each year
well there you go fun fact
[Music]
[Music]
isn't that absolutely gorgeous
beautiful fresh caught fish and chips on
the bank of a river I got some malt
vinegar here I'm gonna put on it
holy mackerel this is this is good stuff
mmm I need some newspaper to wrap this
in this is what I really need good
well the boys weren't too interested in
the catfish so we're gonna go ahead and
roast some hot dogs and just kind of
take it easy get the boys slowly tucked
into bed and we're gonna start getting
serious about trying to catch some more
catfish this is great I've been wanting
to do a camping trip like this for a
long time but this is just really
awesome I'm gonna go ahead and tidy up
the campsite a little bit we get my gear
ready to go and here by sunset we're
gonna start fishing a little bit more
seriously for catfish and see what we
can come up with okay guys I'm gonna
show you a trick here having dealt with
sunburn many many times Tommy's got some
serious sunburn here what we're gonna do
is gonna spray it with the strongest
sunscreen we have before he goes to bed
here okay I feel good if you ever get a
burn spray the highest SPF sunscreen you
got on the burn and keep applying it
until the burns healed up the burn will
heal a lot quicker and won't be as
serious the next morning if you do this
do you want some chocolate cupcakes
hello all right let's see all right I
think it's time we get a little serious
here I'm gonna bait up some of these
rods with some of these dead minnows and
cut up a few of them we're gonna see if
we can't catch something well before he
gets properly dark I'm gonna go ahead
and put some lights on my rod tips I'm
using these whisker sticks they're these
waterproof LED lights run off a little
battery light you just zip tie them to
your rod tip oh they're on there nice
and tight don't come off when you cast
there you go I like to zip tie these
onto my bells and then I could just kind
of put them on and take them off all in
one fell swoop
Oh Mark's got something going on over
there
[Music]
marks fish ran under a snag got off at
least you got your gear back I might
have to switch to bluegill though he's
getting a lot more action than I am guys
into your tent in your tent
guys did you have a wonderful day today
does this you like this camping
alright guys love you just lost another
one
check out that snake yeah beautiful well
it's that time of year again when night
fishing means loads and loads of bugs
geez the lights are bringing them out
yeah it's called Student News
that's a blue catfish see see how he's
got you know you've got a channel cat
and a blue cat
so we've caught one of each
those make good bait that's the start of
the spawn look at the size of his head
is huge yeah he's got a big old head on
him that shows his age and these bumps
on the top they get puffy during the
spawn well there we go got the skunk I
finally caught myself a catfish can't
let mark here get all the luck but just
a little bit longer here and then I
think I'm gonna get to bed
oh the holes don't leave it that's a
catfish right there these water snakes
just everywhere well it's past midnight
and it's time to get some sleep so we're
gonna whine up the rods and get to bed
but I am seeing a crazy number of these
water snakes which makes sense because
there's minnows everywhere and they're
probably hunting those but yeah seen a
lot of snakes tonight anyway I beg you
going to bed I'll see you guys in the
morning
how many do you fight a mosquito camera
yeah you're wiping Nathan big old fish
is jumping right there good morning mark
morning why that's an excellent suntan
you've got working on there yes I worked
hard on that one yesterday Oh
[Music]
Oh Yahweh that's a largemouth bass there
you go good job boys
[Music]
pretty close yeah that feels good that
tastes good well not a bad way to start
the day
sausage burrito and some cake ah
something about getting now around the
equator just you guys want to go further
down that was creepy well this has been
a pretty awesome trip hasn't it Nathan
I'm sure enjoyed it
[Music]
even a fat dad can fit on it hey guys
come over we got we got to leave
oh I think so
[Music]
did you guys have a good time you gonna
do that again sometime if you liked this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click Subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button so you'll get notifications
thanks for watching